jeju is a volcanic island off the coast
of south korea home to halasan the
highest mountain and dormant volcano in
south korea
the island was created entirely from
volcanic eruptions two million years ago
in the cenozoic era check out the
island's lava tubes
the island is also home to the
grandfather stones considered to be gods
offering protection and fertility
[Music]
as well as its beautiful beaches
and uh loveland
let's leave them to it
the island is also home to a secret the
farm where korean air grows and
cultivates food for its first class
passengers
for years korean air has operated
jaedong farm on the island
the farm was originally opened by the
owners of korean air in 1972 when there
was a shortage of beef in korea
cattle were brought in to help supply
the country but by the 90s cows were
everywhere so the farm turned its
attention to more upmarket produce
premium environmentally friendly beef
that's one happy cow
there are several barns holding cows who
will supply beef to korean air's first
and business class passengers
there's also a very large poultry
population and they roam free
the roosters well they're just hanging
out with the ladies
[Music]
peppers were hard to find in korea
so the farm started growing their own
using jeju's clean volcanic artesian
water
and these lovely cherry tomatoes
the island is also home to the best
groundwater in korea
because of the layers of lava flow and
volcanic clusters the island has very
high water absorption
the water is withdrawn from the ground
and bottled here at the state-of-the-art
production plant jeju pure water is
clear and clean mineral water containing
organic components so it's great for you
the water is also being served on korean
air flights in seoul the korean air
chefs are cooking up a treat for the
passengers
here you can see some of the hard work
put in by the farm and the chickens
and how does it taste above the
clouds excellent of course
[Music]